we're here for dr. Gregory Sadler who is
an expert on the Stoics my students have
read for this in preparation the Stoke
Catechism readings from our text but
that's just background and Gregory
Sadler is not only an expert in the
Stoics but he's also a PhD in philosophy
he and I went to grad school together so
we've been every time he comes we
reminisce about those days and he's an
expert in the history of philosophy and
but more particularly using the Stoics I
think as a way to get contemporary folks
connected with philosophy and also sort
of therapeutically
to help them through various issues in
their life and so making philosophy
relevant to real life there's an idea
right yeah so so that's he's also gotta
look very wide and large online presence
including a recent visit just to London
stoic on is that what it was right yeah
there's such a thing as a spoke on can
you believe that
and then that's on video you can
actually watch the lecture the talk you
gave for that online and there's a
myriad other things like tutorials in
philosophy across the internet so
there's little I could sync bunch more
but I'd rather thanks thanks very much
for for inviting me and thanks to the
center for ethics and entrepreneurship
as well I set this up so it could be a
useful introductory lecture for both
intro to philosophy class those who read
the stoic catechism which is largely
drawn from epictetus ascend karidian one
of the really key texts and stoic
philosophy but also would have some
relevance for the business ethics
students some things about leadership
and entrepreneurship really the things
that that stoicism has to offer are of
use to people across the spectrum so
stoicism is an ancient philosophical
system that it's not one of the very
first ones but it becomes one of the
most important philosophical schools of
ancient
times that continues to influence and
affect people in the West all the way
down to the present at some times in a
covert way and other times in a very
overt way and in the last 20 or so years
we've seen a renaissance in interest in
stoicism to the point that the military
is using it for training soldiers and
how to become more resilient
entrepreneurs and tech types are using
it for productivity other people are
using it for self help people who are
interested in cognitive approaches in
psychotherapy are studying it but you
can also go back to the actual text
which was philosopher I think is very
important so we can talk if you want and
I reserve some time for Q&A we can talk
about why it's catching on and why it's
of interest a little bit later today I
want to zero in on certain aspects of it
and since you've got this reading and if
you don't have it in front of you it's
very easy to get you can find it online
Epictetus is enchiridion literally means
the book you can stick in your hand it's
a set of very short chapters it's it's
also a very good stoic text to begin
with I'm gonna focus primarily on them
and I'm going to use Epictetus
and his text is sort of a lens to
provide some stoic lessons that I think
could be useful for you whether you're
going into business whether you're
trying to manage your life as a busy
student probably also working as well
managing family life stress all of that
sort of stuff so what I wanted to do
since we have a really short time here
is give you a really brief overview of
the Stoics school so I'm you know again
each one of these points we could like
spend an entire class session on any one
of them and expand it we can do that in
the Q&A to a limited extent so I'll talk
about how the Stoics get started what
some of their key ideas were and then
how they get down to this guy Epictetus
who's one
they're very late Stoics and why he's
important and a little bit about his
life and then I want to jump right into
the material and the the key idea that I
want this to center around that I think
is of great use particularly in business
contacts is that of self-governance or
self mastery why that if you want to be
a leader you cannot be a leader not only
if you can't follow but if you can't
manage your own life and we see over and
over again entire corporations fail
because the company leadership can't
keep things together in the way that
they ought to they can't manage their
own life so stoicism is not a you know
sort of fix everything an approach to
this but it does provide a lot of useful
perspectives and practices and there's
four main other topics that I thought we
could go into one is called the
dichotomy of control some of you may be
familiar with this already it's not only
the Stoics who talk about this the
serenity prayer any of you familiar with
that the serenity prayer that talks
about it a little bit prices and
priorities how we how we make decisions
what the Stoics call impressions or
appearances and the judgments that
follow from them and then our emotions
and our aspects and attachments these
are not the whole of stoic philosophy
and these aren't even everything that's
covered in the enchiridion so if you've
got questions you read the tacks you
know like hey I want to talk about this
after you know we get through all this
material go ahead and ask about it Ian
by the way if you have questions or if
something's unclear go ahead and
interrupt me I don't have a problem with
that
you're not gonna knock me off track I've
been doing this public speaking stuff
for about 20 years and sometimes it's
good to dwell on things I even
built in a little bit of time for that
anticipating that so alright so first
thing to talk about through the Stoics
who were these guys and they weren't all
guys - there were some female stoic
philosophers unfortunately we don't have
any of their writings but we know that
they existed for example the daughter of
Cato was a a philosopher they get
started with this guy Zeno Gideon who is
not from Athens originally he's from
this colony and he comes in with a ship
load of purple purple dye which was
extremely expensive a luxury product and
he's shipwrecked he gets to literally
see his fortune floating away in the
ocean and while the Mediterranean Sea
and he winds up on shore in Athens down
on his luck we don't know whether he had
any any other resources and he goes to a
book stall now books at that time were
Scrolls you'd actually have to unroll it
and then look at it that that way so it
wasn't like paging through it and he's
reading about this guy Socrates but I
think you've encountered in your
philosophy classes before right Socrates
impressed people by his character and
the book that he's reading is by
Xenophon who is not in a Plato Plato is
the main person that we know about
Socrates through Xenophon portrays this
fairly heroic tough guy Socrates and
Zino's you know thinking how can I be
like this where can I find somebody like
this in the book seller says well you
see that guy over there that's prophets
the cynic philosophy go check him out
and he does so and he studies with him
for about ten years studying meant not
just like showing up the lectures or
completing assignments it meant actually
living with the person and trying to
think of life through their eyes trying
to you might say assimilate yourself to
their their perspective on the world and
learning from their example if you had a
teacher who wasn't really up to par if
they didn't walk the walk but they
talked to talk you could figure that out
pretty quickly by living with them and
the fact that Zeno stuck with cocktails
for 10 years
tells me that the practice was really
you know he was serious about this he
also studied with some other
philosophers so he's getting an influx
from other Socratic schools he studied
at the Academy with still Poe he and he
studied with with Palermo as well and
and so he's drawing all this stuff
together he brings it together in a
synthesis that he doesn't actually call
stoicism that first who here knows what
what stoicism was named after it wasn't
named after Zeno as a matter of fact his
early followers were just called Zenonia
pnes would any of you want to be a
journalist
where do the Stoics get their name from
anyone know sort of a trivia question
know comes from a place to stole a point
Keeley the painted porch these people
literally hung out on the porch and talk
philosophy talked about their problems
trying to figure out how to live their
life and so they became known as the
people of the stoic and eventually it
draws more and more people already in
xenos on lifetime he's got people who
are our leaders after him the king of
Macedon which at that time hadn't taken
over the Greek world but was getting
close asked Zeno to come up and teach
him Zeno sends one of his students and
we know this because there's an actual
existing letter preserved in Diogenes
lair taste that that narrates this so
already it's getting a lot of play you
could say but it's centered in Athens
and then there's followers coming after
that this guy Cleon thisi was a boxer
and a water carrier he was a reliable
kind of guy I didn't make a lot of
innovations and then there's the third
scull our cruciferous who's known as the
second founder of the stoah because by
then this may be something that you have
some experience with the different
philosophical schools were routinely
arguing with each other about everything
attacking each other criticizing each
other and cruciferous was sort of a
champion
stoicism and then we have other guys
coming after him and I'm going to jump
over about you know 200 300 years of
history
eventually stoicism leaves Athens itself
and spreads throughout the entire Greek
speaking and Latin speaking world the
Roman Empire and this is where we get to
what we call the late stop these are the
people that we actually have texts from
unfortunately we don't have texts from
you know he wrote a lot of stuff
all of its gone and we could talk more
about that later the people that we do
have text from are from the later time
we have Seneca who hears heard of not
not the city Seneca or the trade line or
anything like that but the actual person
Seneca anybody he's worth reading with
Sonia it's Rufus we probably if you
haven't heard of Seneca you haven't
heard of him he was at the Tina's his
teacher at the Cheetahs himself you know
about him - you've read him and then who
here has heard of Marcus Aurelius
anybody seen gladiator the movie he with
you is the Emperor at the time one of
the last good ones as they're called
there are only like 5 or 6 good
Emperor's for the whole Roman Empire
they acknowledged as good ones he was
one of the good ones he was a stoic
philosopher and epictetus is sort of at
the heart of this epic penis himself
didn't write down the document that
you're looking at he had a student who
did that and this student was modeling
himself after Xenophon Socrates never
wrote anything down either instead his
students wrote it down Plato is that a
faun a few other people this guy his
name was area and he wrote down a lot of
the dialogues and discourses and
teachings at epic - his head in a big
thick book that's called the discourses
the deitra by literally that it in Greek
you know the the things you say to pass
the time and then he condensed them into
this tiny little document called the
enchiridion nan karidian means the thing
that you could put in n in care hand a
nun little thing the little thing you
can have in your hand and look at
and it through the day so the chapters
there are sort of like a best hits list
and there you notice these providing a
lot of advice Epictetus himself he was a
slave originally he was born into
slavery and then he belonged to another
guy who himself had been a slave but had
risen to become the secretary to Nero
the Emperor one of the bad Emperor's
unfortunately who killed quite a few
people including Seneca eventually he's
freed starts teaching philosophy in Rome
and then gets kicked out why would he
get kicked out of Rome when you think
any any guesses moral turpitude being a
bad guy
drinking too much well now you're on the
right track it wasn't just him though I
heard it's a blanket thing kicking all
the philosophers out of the city of Rome
damn it Ian the Emperor didn't like
philosophers and the Romans were always
a little skeptical about you know what
philosophy was gonna do to their culture
so he kicked them all out and epictetus
goes to Greece and he settles in in
another place opens up a new school and
necropolis and he taught there until he
died and he lived a very simple life
never married fostered a kid we took in
and he was he was quite influential he
was actually visited by another emperor
who wanted to see you know this is this
great man for himself that got Hadrian
you might know from Hadrian's Wall and
and that was that and the Stoics they
had several key ideas in common with
each other so this is not just epictetus
this is this is pretty much all of the
stairs one of these is that virtue moral
virtue determinate ways of being a good
person that's the good that is what
really makes a person good that's what
makes decisions good and so what are the
virtues
who hears heard of you know the virtues
to begin with only nobody only a few
people what are what are some of the
virtues some of you may have had this in
some sort of catechism class or
something like that what are good
character traits yeah what's up well
that would be that wouldn't be a virtue
for the stone temperance yeah you know
that's an old-fashioned word it means
moderation control of your appetites you
know when you look at somebody like
don't take that guy to the bar because
he drinks too much every time you put a
drink in front of him he gets completely
drunk that's in temperance right or
don't take this person to the buffet
because when they do they can't control
themselves and they stuff their face
that that's also in temperance right
being able to control your bodily
appetites so you can actually get other
things done that's that's important you
need that in order to succeed what else
do you need to succeed in life yeah very
important it's one thing to know what
you ought to do it's another thing to
actually see it through the Stoics
viewed courage as dealing with fear but
also as dealing with your other emotions
dealing with for example anger it's not
courageous to like lose your temper and
smack somebody in the face because they
said something mean to you it's actually
courageous not to do that from the stoic
perspective our desires you know being
able to stand up against them dealing
with pain how many of you workout
routinely to go to the gym do you always
want to go to the gym do you want to go
the gym most days that you're in the gym
I sure as hell don't you know but I do
it that's perseverance that's part of
the virtue of courage justice is another
one wisdom or prudence is another one
the stoic said that this is what makes a
person good this
it makes a life good and then you know
correspondingly what makes a life bad is
the opposites of these and everything
else in between fame fortune wealth
pleasure health those things are okay
but they're not the good they're not
really going to make you happy and you
may disagree with them then we just want
to get clear about what they're actually
saying they call those things strictly
speaking indifference meaning that they
don't make a difference to your
happiness or that that doesn't mean that
you know they didn't think they don't
matter at all but they have a limited
value another key idea that they had was
what they called living in accordance
with nature this doesn't mean that they
were all going camping all the time and
you know hugging trees or something like
that or you know only eating natural
food I mean pretty much all food was
natural back then in a sense it's talked
about it today
because it wasn't quite so processed
what it means is figuring out what human
nature fully-developed really is and
trying to live in accordance with that
and also living in accordance with this
universe that we're a part of not
expecting things to be different than
they are you know here's a silly example
right I take these keys out what's gonna
happen when I drop them and it does
anyone think they'll float no they're
gonna fall right that's a natural law
there's other things that are you know
not quite the same thing as physical
laws but you could call them
psychological laws and none of us are
exceptions to those you know if you make
a bad decision you will sooner or later
reap the consequences of that bad
decision make people make bad decisions
all the time thinking they're gonna be
an exception to the rule and they're
gonna escape it
doesn't it doesn't work that way if you
develop bad habits you're gonna become a
slave to those bad habits understanding
that allows you to live in accordance
with nature another key thing when you
hear this word stoic how many of you
before you came in here already had some
sense of what it means to be stoic one
to only a few people okay so what do you
associate the word stoic with
those are you in the back okay so
moderate you could say yeah okay with a
positive attitude we would say do you
think Stoics show emotions no now here I
want to make a distinction between what
we call lowercase s stoicism and then
uppercase s stoicism so the ancient
Stoics were not against emotions and
neither are modern Stoics for the
capital s people who follow the
philosophy there they say that some
emotions are bad for us but not all
emotions are as a matter of fact the
Stoics think that we should live lives
that are filled with joy and rational
desire and taking you know interestingly
one of the things they've been doing all
this empirical research on what it what
happens when you live like a stoic one
of the personality traits that's
associated with that zest it was a kind
of strange result it was the highest
correlation that means enjoying life so
stomachs are not joyless they should
feel love and affection towards people
but some other things depression anxiety
anger these these other emotions they
think that they don't serve a valuable
purpose or so and this is something else
that we can we can talk about later as
well because I know for many that's
going to be a bit of a stretch the way
that Stoics thought you would become
happy was through developing yourself
through something that we could call
self discipline or self mastery so let's
jump in now to actually looking at
epictetus --is and iridium and
one of the things that we should say is
when we're talking about you know self
development or self mastery or whatever
other sort of words we want to tack on
after the - we do in fact have to know
what that self is right so what is
yourself
who are you I mean I look around the
room and I see a whole bunch of people
all right but really it mostly what I'm
seeing on your clothes and your faces
and your hands because we cover up most
of our body not suggesting anyone should
take their clothes off - by the way
perfectly fine with everyone wearing
clothes all the time but you know we
have your face and we have your outer
apparel that auto-repair well that's not
you you may feel that it expresses your
personality or it could be just you know
you woke up late and through what I
throw on whatever you could write that's
it that that's the way I dress sometimes
but it's not you as a matter of fact
even your bodily features are not really
you although the government you know
with all the tracking software pretty
soon we'll be identified with that with
the facial recognition software that
that's that's being used in some places
what is you what's the core of your
person what stays the same over time or
what changes deep inside of you and
makes the changes that really count I
mean you can change your appearance if
you want that doesn't make you a good
person does it it doesn't make you happy
for any lasting amount of time people go
and get makeovers but that doesn't that
makes me happy for a little bit it
doesn't make you happy for four lon what
does a person what do you think well I
know what the Stoics think and I'll tell
you about that what do you think
yeah okay so your thoughts that's
definitely you know your ethics and
morals I mean you can see that it's like
the ways in which you make decisions the
values by which you guide yourself
I mean I'm 13 us I think would go along
with that he calls what's most core
within you
there's a Greek term for it parlez
racist which literally means grasping
one thing in advance or grasping one
thing instead of another another way you
can translate it preference our order of
preferences it's the part of you that
makes decisions some people talk about
this in terms of you know neuroscience
as executive function right he also uses
other terms he calls he talks about the
governing or ruling faculty that's the
same thing it's just viewed in a
different light our rationality is also
part of this in your text that you have
the anchor it Ian prior Asus is
translated in different ways depending
on who's doing the translating it can be
translated as moral purpose will faculty
of choice it's the part of you that
actually makes the decisions whether
you're realizing you're making a
decision or not and it determines what
we do and think and feel and here's
where it gets really interesting it can
be determined by other things so you
could ask yourself how the hell did I
get here you made some decisions right
but your decisions were conditioned or
determined by somebody else or some
other factors outside or you could say
you were programmed to respond in
certain ways right that that's all true
but there's also a part of yourself that
can step back from the programming and
say I don't like this part of myself I
think this needs to change a great
example of this is when people have a
string of bad relationships one after
the other are they just unlucky do they
just wind up with the wrong kind of
person the wrong type
and it's just you know so sad that they
keep on you know landing the same
boyfriend/girlfriend and what whatever
what's the common element in both sorts
of situations you date a whole string of
jerks what's the common element you yeah
there's something about the choices
you're making that's leading to getting
stuck with a bunch of losers
over and over and over again you could
look at that part of yourself and say oh
maybe I don't have to do things that way
anymore
and you can do this across the board
with all sorts of things one thing that
I wanted to say is from stomache
perspective you're not special that's
the bad news
right you're not special at all the same
things that apply to every other human
being applied to you you're not an
exception to it the good news about this
is you're not special that means that if
you want to figure out how to make your
life better you can use the same sort of
techniques and ideas that people have
been applying for hundreds or sometimes
thousands of years because human nature
has not fundamentally changed you do
matter you are a person you do have
value but you're not totally unique in
the sense of being radically different
from other people you have the same sort
of Faculty of choice as epictetus did
and the good news about this is once you
start to realize that it gives you some
room to maneuver now why is this
important from again from a leadership
perspective those of you who are the
business ethics students why would it be
important as an entrepreneur or as
somebody moving into management's or
even somebody dealing with individual
clients why is it important to
understand who you are and how your
might
works can you think of situations where
that would be particularly valuable this
may not be something you thought of
before you may think that you know you
just go to school and learn some
business principles and how to put
together a plan and do your spreadsheets
and all these sorts of things and go out
and start you know making cold calls or
developing leads no there's that that's
all great but that won't make you
succeed or are you gonna train for HR
and you're gonna learn how to fill all
these different forms out and comply
with all these different regulations
that's good that won't make you succeed
if you're running into snags over and
over again if you can't rule yourself if
you can't govern yourself you're really
not going to be successful if you are
it'll just because you're lucky in that
situation and that won't last for very
long what allows people to become
resilient is being able to control
themselves to understand themselves and
that's that's stoicism is not the only
way to do that but epictetus is offering
you the tools for it right here in this
this karidian document let's talk about
another thing now we're getting a little
bit more of a deep dive Stoics called us
like the economy of control the text
that you actually have here talks about
it as being up to us some things are up
to us other things are not up to us to
be translated as in our control in our
power not in our control not our power
could even be translated as some things
are our business other things are none
of our business and notice the sort of
things that epictetus says are not in
our control some of them are you know
you would probably agree with right off
the bat is your reputation fundamentally
in your control or can other people you
know in just an instant damage
I mean it's in your control to a certain
extent if you post all sorts of horrible
stuff on Facebook or on Twitter people
aren't probably not going to like you
and they're gonna say bad things about
you you can build your reputation but
all it takes is one screw-up especially
these days with social media and you can
become a meme right this has happened to
people I took a few means fortunately
the people who do memes of my stuff like
me so nobody's put anything really
horrible yet but sooner or later it's
gonna happen you know with some picture
or screenshot what about your property
things you know are those things totally
in your control let's take your clothes
right you're wearing a clothes right now
if somebody who is gonna come up to you
and try to take them away from you you
probably could resist them right it's
not like acid is gonna drop from the
ceiling and burn your clothes off or
anything like that but yeah take them
off and go to the laundromat and put
them in the dryer and turn away for a
couple minutes somebody can come right
along and take that nice you know you'll
never see it again right and you may buy
another one it'll never be quite the
same as that that sweatshirt that you
have right now what about your body what
about health what about your appearance
those things Epictetus says are not
fully within your control
I mean there's aspects of our body that
are clearly not in our control right
that would any of you like to be taller
or shorter thinner fatter have different
habits I mean if you want to change your
hair color just go buy some dye but that
won't really make you that color will it
you can buy contacts and you can do all
sorts of things but you're stuck with
the body that you've got I mean trust me
it's somebody who's pushing 50 you know
I know the difference between old me and
young me who's not old me and and the me
that I've got right now no that doesn't
mean that you can't come you can't have
any determination of that do I have a
choice about how I eat or whether
exercise or whether I go to the doctor
or not or turns out one of the things we
found out you know in the last 10-15
years whether you brush your teeth or
not is very important why because those
bacteria can cause all sorts of other
problem sure but I could die from bird
flu you know I could be as healthy as I
want to be and walk out
I live on in in the middle of Milwaukee
so I could walk across the street and
then here comes the bus and that's it
for me right we can we can look at all
sorts of things as being fundamentally
out of our control that doesn't mean
that you shouldn't pay attention to them
or take it and care about them but you
should realize with every single one of
those things that you don't actually
have control over and we make ourselves
anxious angry fearful depressed all
these negative reactions by assuming
that we have control over things that we
actually don't what do we actually have
control over if that's the case we don't
have control over those other things
what do you think we actually do have
control over
[Music]
so that's that's a good example of
something where it's up to somebody else
right so somebody made a policy and you
don't have any control over whether they
make the policy you could decide screw
it I'm not going to follow the policy
but then if they want to apply sanctions
to you you have control over that right
and there's lots and lots of things like
that in our life a lot of people would
like to not pay their taxes you know for
example but I mean you can not pay your
taxes but sooner or later the IRS will
catch up with you and then they'll have
a very bad conversation with you which
you might not like right so those are
all examples of things that Epictetus
would say those are up to somebody else
they're not really up to us the things
that he says they're in our control are
our thoughts and actually our feelings
and our desires and aversions the things
that are more core to who we are those
are up to us those are within our power
you might say well how can I stop myself
from feeling this feeling that I have
right well you can't just snap your
fingers and not feel that way think
about a terrible breakup or even worse
think about when you lose a job that you
really enjoyed and you're gonna bad
economy or you lose a client that you
that you need for your starting business
that really hurts right and you can't
make that not hurt right then but you
can determine what you do in terms of
reaction to it do you go home in life
you know knock the bookshelf over and
swear at people or go out and you know
as we say drown your sorrows that's up
to you
you can't choose what you do you take it
out on employees co-workers friends
that's up to you you can change your
habits and your mindset so that you
don't have so strong reaction
to those those things that is within
your control another thing that he talks
about is is prices and priorities for
things the top priority for a stoical
would be keeping your the center of your
very being keeping who you are in
accordance with nature and making
progress and ultimately being a happy
person not just happy once in awhile but
consistently to have what Epictetus
called a smooth flow of life doesn't
that sound good have your life going
along without impediments in in chapter
38 he says that when you're walking
around you would be careful not to step
on a nail right you wouldn't want to
damage your foot now some of you may be
a little accidental I'm actually kind of
clumsy I break things all the time
but in general we avoid physical
problems right why not do that with your
mind why not do that with the core of
who you are why allow that to be damaged
because you value it less than you value
your body and that's you know it's okay
to realize that the Stoics that say once
you've realized that then start changing
your priorities if you know that that
heading into certain situations stresses
you the hell out then start your
removing yourself from those situations
or figuring out how you're gonna deal
with them productively don't just avoid
them you know pretend like they're not
going to happen and then have to deal
with that once you're stuck there that
that's you know a way of changing your
priorities he also talks in in Chapter
12 and you're missing chapter 4 in this
translation but he talks about what do
you do when negative things happen I
think I'm this has to do with your
priorities so he talks about he's doing
with servants right a little oil gets
spilled a little bit of wine gets stolen
imagine instead now you're in the
workplace what are what are some things
all of you worked I'm sure different
jobs what are the things that tick you
off about your co-workers or bosses or
customers really tick you off pet
they an attitude okay that's that's a
really great one right somebody comes in
customers can have bad attitudes you
know they're snotty with you they want
you to be as we call johnny-on-the-spot
and deal with their stuff right away and
you know like you know I'm still dealing
with another customer over here they're
very demanding
after you do what they want they're
still demanding they're always trying to
get something out of you there's a
couple ways you could look at that you
know here's where you want to think
about what your priorities are is your
priority to have customers treat you the
way that you want to be treated or as
your cut is your priority to get through
the workday or is your priority to
provide good customer service regardless
of whether the customer is a jerk about
those are different priorities those are
going to determine not just how you
behave but how you feel and once you
feel better about these sorts of
exchanges once you can sort of let
things go you're actually going to feel
more free and you're gonna find that you
have more energy and more ability to
look at situations so you have to ask
yourself is is something worth getting
upset about if it is it's because you've
invested that thing with the importance
and that's a choice on your part that
you can unmake we also make wrong
inferences about who or what is valuable
at this great line some of you may have
you know read this and responded to it
these sorts of arguments are invalid I'm
richer than you are therefore I'm better
than you don't we often say that I mean
if we're being rational we wouldn't say
that right I mean there is a thing that
he says you can deduce from that I am
richer there than you therefore my
possessions are better than yours true
you know somebody's got a nicer car than
mine they've they've got a nicer car
than my car but that doesn't actually
mean that they're better than I am he's
got another one here I am more eloquent
than you therefore I am better than you
I can speak better than you can
therefore I'm better than you is that
true no I mean it could be that that you
are actually better than the other
person but there's no necessary
connection between these we make these
sort of inferences over and over and
over again automatic we live in a
culture that's constantly providing us
with cues to see things this way if you
can break that habit that will provide
you with more freedom again another
example that he talks about and there's
a handout that we'll be sending it to
you that we were gonna have for this
originally it's how to deal with
impressions of pleasure he talks about
this in chapter 34 so I'm just gonna
actually read this when you receive an
impression of a certain pleasure be on
your guard just as you are with other
impressions lest you get carried away
with it take your time with the thing
wait awhile next call the mind both
times what what times the time when you
will enjoy the pleasure and the time
when after enjoying it you will change
your mind and scold yourself set against
these the thought of how if you abstain
you will rejoice and praise yourself but
if it still seems to be the proper
occasion to indulge it after you've
thought it over you think it's good then
you know how much better it will be to
be conscious of yourself as having won
the victory so what he's saying there is
think through before you give into stuff
you know when when you're making
decisions about what to do where to
place your time where to place your
money where to place your effort
think about your ordering of priorities
think about whether what you're doing is
actually going to get you to where you
want to be and if you're tempted to go
somewhere that's a sign that you
actually haven't got your priorities all
figured out yeah that's okay you know
that's a starting point but now it's
time to actually put them into
perspective you notice he talks about
appearances or impressions there that's
another key stoic idea so what are
appearances
this is a really basic concept right now
I'm talking at you right and you are
seeing me here those are appearances
those are things that are impinging from
without upon you after I leave if you
remember me
you have memories of those appearances
could be that I don't actually exist
here it could be that that you know Matt
set up a hologram and he was tricking
you and I never existed in the first
place which is a super clever computer
programmer
you know that's within the realm of
possibility none of you probably thought
of that before you came in here now
you're all you know considering that but
dismissing the possibility probably all
right everything that we do in life
involves appearances or impressions it's
up to us whether we automatically assent
to them whether we automatically think
that they're the way that they're
presenting themselves so I'll give you
an example from like years and years of
teaching right
it's after lunch how many of you are a
little bit tired right now
nearly all the class right maybe because
they ate lunch now you're digesting it
so I can look out at the the audience
and be like that person is not really
that into this you know and now what
I've got is an appearance and I concert'
reading things into the appearance right
any of the talk isn't going that well
maybe maybe they have a bad attitude
maybe and we can go on and on and where
we go wrong much of the time is in
automatically reading all those things
in right those are judgments that we're
making we control what our judgments are
at least to some degree you know takes a
little bit of practice to start getting
used to that but once you do it you can
start realizing just how many judgments
you're constantly making now would this
give some application within again I'm
dealing with customers clients employees
even thinking about larger scale things
like looking at economic forecasts or
how much your your you know you're
bringing in in terms of cash flow you
you can look at how things are
presenting themselves without making all
these judgments about it or at least
just pausing for a moment that's why
epictetus says for every harsh
appearance stop and just you know sit
with it for a second and say you're only
in appearance you're not what you
pretend to be necessarily it could be
that the thing that looks really bad
really is bad or it could be that you're
reading too much into it
and so stoicism would say that's very
important to to do he also has another
good line several times in here he talks
about people insulting us and he says
it's not actually the person insulting
us that hurts us what is it that hurts
us or it could be somebody like smacking
you or you know destroying your property
could be your arch rival in business you
know showing you up at the meeting with
a better report than your own
deliberately to screw you over
right sort of things will be making the
movies and TV shows that doesn't really
happen that much in real life as far as
I can tell people aren't quite so
coordinated as that you have you know
what would what seems to be happening
then you'd have your judgement about it
do you have a choice in how you you look
at somebody let's say somebody really is
being insulting you know let's say you
guys all came in here and I and I was
like let me tell you you know I'm almost
50 years old and I have a PhD you are
just a bunch of young Millennials you
don't know anything you know if I'm
saying stuff like that would you be a
little bit off put now maybe I'm doing
that because I'm having a aneurysm or
something's going wrong with my brain
right or maybe I'm doing it cause I'm a
jerk and I want to I want to stick it to
you right I mean right now we're
imagining it and I'm I'm doing this sort
of stuff just to make a point but let's
say I was that that guy right I'm gonna
lecture you nobody gets to ask any
questions because you obviously don't
have anything to say you know we just go
on and on like that it would still be up
to you how you want to approach that
situation you could say wow that guy's
got some problems something's gone
evidently gone wrong in his life I guess
he's not a very happy person and I guess
he doesn't really understand how to
speak to audiences very well alright or
you could say I'm gonna argue with him
you know I'm gonna show him that's not a
productive strategy
the Stoics would say you know this is
where you get that you can pick things
up by one handle or by the other handle
again one of the points that Epictetus
makes in there the last thing that I
want to hit on very quickly and then
we've got a little bit of time actually
only a very little time for questions
emotions a FX and attachments so like I
said the Stoics don't think that we
should be unemotional they do think that
a lot of our emotions stem from
judgments if I get angry and anger is
one of the most complex of the emotions
it's because I judge that somebody is
doing something wrong to me or to
somebody else that I identify with care
about and responsible for or even
something like if somebody's criticizing
philosophy I'm like you're not going to
criticize my field you know that's me
making a judgment and if you can head
off those judgments or at least analyze
them and examine them you can be less
angry you can also be less sad you can
be less anxious which also then frees
you up for feeling the other emotions
which are from a stoic perspective not
only good to feel but the sort of things
that you want to be feeling you know
there's rational amount of pleasure we
call that joy and it takes a lot of
different forms there's a rational way
to desire they they don't have a very
good translation for that it's usually
translated as wish but you know when I
told people I was getting excited to go
to stoic on some of my you know fellow
people and the movement where like
Stoics don't get excited
that's a lack of control I was like
stomachs get excited
that's just rational desire for
something that I'm anticipating as being
a good thing even fear sometimes we want
to feel it right rational amount of fear
taking a new class with an unfamiliar
professor who's got a better reputation
for being tough would you feel a little
sense of worry about whether you're
gonna do well in the class or not yeah
should that need you to like you know
going into their office hours shaking
like a leaf
you know trembling voice or something
like that flashbacks yeah we probably
are too you know that's not a rational
amount of fear and we think oh we could
go much further with this I want to
leave a little bit of time I know we're
almost at the end of the time allotted
but I'll stick around if anybody's got
any questions or comments wants to go on
further with this material yeah
yeah and virtue Stoics are pretty
similar to whatever so let's say some of
the time like I'm anger with Stoics
angers always bad Aristotle thinks that
there was a good kind of anger so the
Stoics don't think that the world itself
is malevolence as a matter of fact they
think they're sort of more committed to
the this part of the world being a
rational system that actually makes
sense but the people in the world a lot
of them are screwed up this is actually
kind of a problem you know for Stoics to
explain exactly how that happens but you
know marcus aurelius says that famous
start of book two he says when you wake
up in the morning remind yourself that
you're gonna run into people who are
ungrateful conniving just a bunch of
lists of ways people are jerks and but
the reason he tells them himself that is
so that he can he can deal with them as
a good person he doesn't have to like
beat he doesn't have to follow their
loud wall and and all that but he's just
reminding himself with a way people are
Aristotle has remarks like that like in
the rhetoric where he says that the
audiences are almost always bad people
so but it kind of varies where we're
looking any other your questions or
comments quickly I don't want to hold
you over too long I know you have other
classes to get to an emotional thanks to
our
you